Hillary how has this experience been for
you it's been magical it's been so
wonderful I love being pregnant
Hilary Swank's a proud new mom the Oscar
winner welcomes twins with husband
Phillip Schneider this is um something
that I've been wanting for a long time
back in October Hillary shocked the GMA
crew with her happy news I'm gonna be a
mom
yeah I'm gonna be a mom and not just the
one but of two oh really yeah
we probably should have led with that
that sounds like a oh my goodness
congratulations thank you and it's so
nice to be able to talk about it and
share it over on the gram she told fans
by sharing baby bum snaps in writing
coming soon double feature and double
features run in the family what does
like what does twins mean that's twins
means too yeah my grandmother was a twin
my husband's grandmother was a twin oh
my God so we have twins in our in our
lineage in your DNA yes when I heard the
news I'm like are you like I knew you
like you were my friend thank you thank
you for that yeah and it's just nice to
see a lot of women in their 40s going
you gave me hope I'm not you know
because once you really believe
something that can happen you like have
a different thought pattern you know
what I mean you get out of your own way
during the holidays Hillary got in the
festive Spirit captioning this pic of
her growing belly so grateful for these
two gifts of a lifetime if I would say
day in and day out I'm very blessed in
January the first time parents to be
stepped out for the Golden Globes at
three months
three months to just yeah well all my
friends because I have three friends in
their 40s who all got pregnant with
twins and they were all like no you have
about a month and a half because in
about a month and a half you're not
going to want to be walking around and I
just feel so blessed and so happy
happier than I've ever felt
[Music]